good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i am proud to
welcome you to our final edition of our 2021
2022 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series has been
supported by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grants from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme has been ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence and biomedicine where we
have enjoyed presentations on fridays from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities and the
hurdles associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected participants in
our biomedical data science innovation lab program
have been able to leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person grant
project development workshop to be held here next
month in charlottesville virginia i am delighted
to welcome our speaker today and the final speaker
of our series dr brian wright from the school of
data science here at the university of virginia
dr wright is one of our 2021 2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab mentors and he
serves currently as an assistant professor
and the director of undergraduate programs
at the university of virginia's school
of data science he holds degrees from the
university of tennessee including a phd in higher
education and higher education administration
and an mpa in public administration and a
bachelor of science in economics prior to joining
the university of virginia in 2019 dr wright
developed the masters of data science program
at george washington university where he taught
for several years and while at george washington
he founded their data science institute and
helped to develop the creation of a joint phd
in education and in data science dr wright began
his career with the department of defense as a
management consultant and researcher with a focus
on enterprise resource planning and conversation
a conversion excuse me in continuing our
2021-22 biomedical data science seminar series
brian's lecture today is entitled instilling
diversity into a data science undergraduate
curriculum dr wright will discuss with us the
process of helping to build the very first
data school of data science in the country and
this will include the necessity of developing
an agreed-upon definition of data science
instilling diversity into an undergraduate
program and providing opportunities to
shape undergraduate under education and
data science as a field that is inclusive
diverse and uh exciting and forward-thinking
in his lecture he will um also include specific
examples that have proven effective in other stem
oriented fields and we're really looking
forward to his lecture al as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for recording by
youtube and if you're watching on youtube thank
you so much for joining us also our specially
selected 2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants are encouraged to submit any
questions for brian by the chat feature in their
zoom sessions and i will synthesize these and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or
so of the lecture and with that welcome brian
we are really looking forward to your lecture
great thanks so much for the uh kind words and
introduction jack i will i'll just jump right
into it here uh so uh this is the title we're
going to create talk about creating a diverse
undergraduate bachelor's of data science this is
me i guess we already did most of this so i'll
just jump kind of to the next slide here i want
to foreground this with i don't assume to have
all of the answers it's a very complicated space
you know there's lots of solutions you know so
sometimes the best way to prove that they work is
to actually implement them and so we're going to
look through some research that has done just
that but i'm going to hit some key highlights
that i think are pretty important and the context
behind this which i think is important to have
is that we are actually in the process and jack
knows this very well because he's on my committee
that's helping me do this is that we are in the
process of developing the undergraduate bachelor
of science here uh at the school of data science
at uva so this will be the first undergraduate
full degree inside the school so we have kind
of a nice opportunity to think about exactly
what we wanted to look like and to instill
some of these best practices that we know
from research can really help in terms of just
getting diversity and keeping that diversity
in the school in forms of retention so uh i got
about six points to cover all right i'll try and
go through some some of them will be a bit more
in-depth um and like i said i don't assume to have
all the answers here um but these are ones that i
have uh either implemented in the past or have uh
you know kind of taken a look at through other
research avenues that we know to that that we
know that work okay so let's jump right into
it so so the first thing and i i know this has
been covered a lot but like the way that i think
about this what is data science i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna try and frame it um but what i do want
people to think of it as for this point of this
talk is that it really is kind of this once in a
generation maybe even more right opportunity so
i can contextualize what that means here at the
school of data science at uva given we're the
first one in the country but even more broadly
than that you don't get that many opportunities
um when we think about the life cycle of academic
uh endeavors to actually build a new field
right especially a new stem field so when we think
about data science we can all debate about whether
that's the content of how much ces or stats but i
think really what it represents especially for the
context of this conversation is just this amazing
opportunity to say to ourselves how can we build
a culture and a field that you know kind of sets
aside some of the ills that we have with current
stem education we know um in terms of the ways
that people get into it or the retention rates
or the diversity measures there so we really have
this amazing you know kind of you know once in
a lifetime possibly the opportunity to do that
and uh and so that's the context for this i want
to think about it that way as we as we kind of
move through this and i have some foregrounding
slides here i'll just talk about kind of the
rapid growth of data science you know we would
talk about we're kind of beginning to define it
was largely built pretty much in the in the in
the master space right so we have this chart here
from the advanced analytics center there at north
carolina state uh and they just show here that
the rapid you know kind of the incredible growth
of uh data science programs in the united states
you know kind of beginning around down here in the
mid you know 2010s and then now we're we're way
up here you know pushing you know 350 programs
almost all of which are in um in the graduate
space and the particular side isn't the graduate
space so the next kind of frontier um for data
science is is largely in the undergraduate space
there are some phd programs those have tends to
be a bit more specialized but what we see now in
relation to this trend is that likely this type
of chart will be duplicated probably for the 2020s
but in the undergraduate space there are
many many programs at least i talked to
other program directors uh around the country
or other schools and other associations that
we're involved with and they're all thinking about
developing undergraduate programs and so we have
kind of this we're at this unique point here
when we think about how we you know have stem
education and undergraduate is a foundation uh of
people moving through and getting phds in these
particular fields increasing diversity to really
take advantage of it because we're on kind of the
front end of this curve so that's kind of the
foreground at least for the undergraduate space
all right this is just an another chart there
showing the number of students that have
graduated i think we're pushing cumulative
numbers over 50 000 now in terms of just
graduate data science degrees that
have been awarded all right oh and
this is just a fun chart i want to show this
this is a variety of courses actually in my
just kind of it's kind of a biased sample
here but this is a distribution of majors
in my machine learning undergraduate course
and you can see here and i think this is
you know for the context of this nice to see
that there are neuroscience we have biomedical
engineering but the point here is that we have
a variety of uh majors everything from english
and economics have a lot of computer science
here but a lot of students and a lot of different
undergraduate majors really interested in
data science and these are students that
are declared for the data science minor here at
uva of which we have about 300 and this is just
a sample from just my undergraduate classes about
60 students where they're coming from so this kind
of mirrors this idea that not only do you know
could we see this potential really large growth
but also that we're going to see you know a lot
of interest from a lot of variety of different
degrees right and this could be analogous to a
lot of variety of different types of students so
again kind of a nice point in time to think about
what is a data science undergraduate degree and
what what do we what are the best practices that
we can create and support in order to make sure
that that's a healthy stem environment all right
so uh to continue to fork around here we've seen
a lot of growth in stem you know i think some of
this is actually a bit underestimated but you know
since 1990 to to 2019 here we've seen it basically
double you know it's about 30 of all the degrees
conferred in the united states right now right we
still have some issues with stem in terms of just
diversity generally and we think about centering
on women here there was a share of stem that grew
over the same period from 32 to 34 um over these
10-year period that's not that's not much growth
and consideration of the total population of women
that have gone to school over that same period of
time and then here that we see that there's some
performance measures that are different between
students that are actually in bachelor's degrees
in data science or district degrees in stem at 44
that actually make it in to workforce positions
there's probably lots of reasons for that but i
think a big reason that we might be concerned
relative to this is that there appears to be
a proportion of um you know skilled technical
workforce that's been totally unchanged right over
the over 10 years um and so if we dig a little
bit deeper into this the distribution of women
in bachelor's degrees in stem is also a bit huge
right actually pretty heavily skewed towards
life sciences or social sciences and the ones that
are probably most analogous right to data science
are probably these three right so physical
science but especially computer science
and engineers so we think of the percentage
of distribution of women in stem fields here
and this is all from 2019 pretty low in terms of
computer and mathematical sciences and then also
engineer so we have again kind of an opportunity
here to do things a bit better to help balance
this out especially in consideration that women
now make up a majority of the total enrollments in
higher education we dig a little bit deeper here
we see these same problems there seems to be some
you know kind of misrepresentation
of uh blacks hispanics and american
indians and alaskan natives they make up about
30 percent of the total population but only 20
of the stem workforce right so they're largely
under represented and this came out of that same
national science foundation kind of report
about why the reasons for this that might
occur and that you know they're they're kind
of driving uh force through this through this
publication here was about the need to create
a better pipeline for stem workers especially
as it relates to getting them access to bachelor's
degrees or higher education generally all right
uh so this again i guess to overemphasize this
point this is the distribution across different
um racial groups here in terms of just
uh people receiving all right science and
engineering degrees in 2019 you see here
that there's a pretty disproportionate
percentage associated with hispanics as it
relates to associate degrees as compared
to bachelor's degrees and you can compare that
to where we're sitting for the white population
of students it's also true for for black and
the other minorities that are here all right
so it seems like there's they're getting into
these associate degree programs right but
that proportion doesn't necessarily carry over
right into the bachelor's degrees which we know
is linked to kind of the most workforce success
and creative foundation for all sorts of other
things in terms of just a healthy society of
people coming up and being able to contribute
to the scientific community all right all right
so uh this is actually in in spite of a rather
significant investment in stem education from the
federal government alright so the congressional
research service you know that estimates that
the federal government spends about 3.1 billion
just in stem education programs these aren't stem
related grants or supporting of research that's
just stem education programs and that's adjusted
for inflation between the periods of 2010 and
2020. so that's a lot that's that's i didn't have
to do that for you that's 31 billion dollars over
the last decade of investment in stem education
programs a lot of which was designed to increase
diversity uh and create these pathways and
we've seen from the previous slides that that
have marginal effects at best so we have to
think of ways that maybe we can improve this
all right and there's just fun facts here the
un estimated at 30 billion or actually solve
the uh global food crisis all right so that's
that's an important note just in scale of what
30 billion dollars can do you could hire a half a
million new public school teachers with that money
and then um the last one kind of less fun i guess
you could not that's not enough to buy twitter so
uh sorry elon okay but 30 billion dollars quite
a lot of money all right so let's talk about
ways that we can design undergraduate programs
that that we know have proven based off research
and um and uh and and i'll talk about how
we're thinking about implementing that as
we're developing this new undergraduate program
here at uva so the first ways is uh to have
multiple pathways and to minimize competitive
nature of these programs i know that can sound
antithetical but the idea here is to give it's
basically to be high flex to provide lots of ways
to come into the program and then let competition
occur once they're in not before all right doesn't
mean that we reduce the rigor or the quality of
these programs we still want them to be very high
but we want to be able to be flexible to try and
get students in and then once they're in providing
the necessary supports and then keep that maintain
that level of rigor that we know is necessary for
learning right i'm going to talk there's a lot to
talk about here but given the time that we have
i'm going to try and focus on first the
relationships with two-year schools and then i'll
touch some of these other ones when we think about
just multiple pathways in the relationship with
two-year schools tends to be a really important
one all right so this is just this is from the um
american association of community colleges
they put out this infographic here
there's to highlight some of the facts here
associated with this you'll see that the
diversity measures associated with students coming
in to two-year degrees over here it tends to be a
quite a bit higher than we see it's kind
of natural not actually that much more but
quite a bit uh at least at least in terms of
just the number of students there certainly
certainly larger and we all think that other
demographics of first generation students
that are in community colleges it's a bit
hard to read but down here this number
in particular that's about 30 percent some of them
are single parents add those together right so 30
is much larger than the national average for first
generation students which is around 20 so there's
a significant portion of generation students and
minority students that go into two-year schools
right which is uh makes it an important avenue
for us to understand and create pathways with
into four-year degrees so having relationships
with two-year schools in order to be able to
encourage diversity is is significant and there's
some some facts over here on the side right that
among african-american or black students that
graduate with a gpa of 3.5 or higher 33 percent
of them attend a community college that's a high
number right that's closer to 22 percent for white
or caucasian so we can see this can really be uh
an important thing to consider when we're talking
about creating pathways into into four-year
programs um to encourage diversity all right this
is just to give you an idea of the total number of
two years is from the same same institution here
and so we can see that over time we've
had kind of steady increases in the number
of enrollments in education generally for a year
we're up here around 10 million all right but a
significant portion of that all right maybe close
to i think it's 45 percent something like that is
in two-year programs right we've seen actually
a pretty big drop in this over time in covid
you know pandemic didn't make this much better
when it's fluctuations in terms of economic
realities or you know a global pandemic usually
two-year schools are the ones that suffer the most
because the students that enroll in those
are forced to do other things decide
attend from school besides attend school
but we can see here that it does make up
a significant portion of the total population
of those attending post kind of post-primary
education programs all right all right so
relationships with two-year schools i want
to highlight some things here too about um what i
mean by that all right so really what i'm talking
about is developing at least this is kind of what
the educational research would tell us is that
a lot of what restricts students
from understanding what they can do
well after they're done with their two-year
program is actually their ability to have access
to that information right to understand that there
are these transfer programs all right that that
they can talk to counselors they can be admitted
into four-year programs there's direct admits
uh so a lot of that that that understanding of
the world of possibilities is is encapsulated with
this idea about social capital is that minority
students first generation students especially
don't have the same amount of social capital
that that students students that come from um
parents that have gone through this process or
have um bachelor's degrees right or even higher
they just don't have uh relationships that allow
them to understand what the potential options are
and advantages right of going from two year
to four year and so vincent tito tinto was
the original framework of this and he associated
social capital with kind of educational isolation
right and he was the one that created
original framework about how this can lead to
to drop out rates and retention turnover um year
over year in four-year degrees so his idea about
essentially that um dropout is very similar to
social isolation and that is akin to kind of this
lack of social capital that students have on
campus and that can come in the representation
of peers or faculty members or family members
there's the idea that that is a significant
contributor and there's now a huge body of
research he did this back in them actually
started in the 80s but a huge body of research to
support this idea about kind of how right social
capital can make a huge difference in terms of
students having success across the board all right
there's a bunch of studies that show that this
type of social capital can be gained through peer
and fam and faculty engagement all right these are
some examples here all right so this particular
article kind of did a lot of interviews across
23 different institutions all right and it found
that especially in the latino community there
was a significant difference between students
that successfully navigated through the community
college and then and on to four-year degrees that
had strong relationships with their adult males
right in their family that did the same thing or
male faculty members that helped them kind
of understand what the pathways were right
so there were some significant differences
there that's one example right and this is
an example from some work that i did earlier
that associated with this that there was a
a significant difference in terms of
engagement and peer mentorship as it relates
to social capital for first generation students
when compared to non-first generation students
in terms of their level of success on
campus all right so what we see here and
there's there's lots of like i said studies
that support this is that this type of um
this type of designing programs and started to
understand what what it means to develop this
social capital for students to facilitate it can
really make a difference in terms of how students
are transitioning or being successful through
this two year to four-year pipeline all right
this is another one uh that was
especially relevant here that talked about
you know community college across california
that they reviewed 42 community colleges
and what they did is they worked
and created recommendations about
how to create programs at four-year
institutions that could essentially
allow uh students of african-american descent to
gain to gain more social capital in the forms of
building relationships with existing institutions
in order to be able to reduce that student
equity gap in terms of their transition out of
community college into four-year institutions okay
there's a link here i think for the sake of time
i probably won't click on it but there are lots of
transfer success programs right that are making
actually a pretty huge difference this particular
site has a few of them on there there's actually
several in virginia they're from george patient
virginia tech and vcu uva has has ones as well
especially as it relates to its uh to the college
of wise um and so the idea is that a lot of these
these transfer programs um are kind of giving
boots on the ground going out to the community
colleges and talking about um how students can
transfer the pipelines the requirements for that
and then even going further to match them with
peer mentors that have done that process right
that are successfully transferred and are doing
well in the academic environment in that college
and that that can make huge differences that will
actually dive a little bit more into that but not
just giving them a flyer and saying hey these are
the opportunities but actually allowing them
to connect with people that have successfully
done it and really kind of rely on them to to
provide advice can make a big difference okay
other ways that we talk about kind of um you know
multiple pathways in and out of degree that's one
that you know from from two-year schools in
particular is an important one when we think
about kind of injecting diversity but also inside
the program the way that we've designed it is that
we do have a minor which is essentially the first
four classes that students would take in the major
so that if they're not sure that they want to do a
data science major they can start with a minor and
then they can build credits see if it's a right
fit for them and if it is then they can jump into
the program it turns out that they come into the
data science minor or date science major and it
is not right for them all right one thing that
they can do is they can leave with a credential
and get the minor right so after the first year
if they just think hey this isn't right for me
uh then they they don't lose those credits so to
speak right they can off-ramp out of the major and
still receive the minor then move on to something
maybe that that might be more you know connected
to their personal interests the other thing that
we're making sure to do is that we're connecting
it with the other liberal arts requirements on
campus so again that these students aren't losing
credits as they go through our program that they
can take these credits if they decide to stay or
even double major is is a big thing um that they
won't lose those credits there's a big there's a
lot of information and and studies relative to
credit accumulation and student success so both
of these are related to making sure that students
don't fall behind if they happen to change their
plans while on grounds um and they can still you
know accumulate credits at a that would be a a a
appropriate rate for them to graduate within four
years all right we're also going to have multiple
application periods this is kind of akin to
what we just talked about with on and off
we are going to allow for one time first
admissions just direct admit they'll apply to uva
if you get into uva then you can say that hey i'd
like to be a data science major and then you'd
start that right after your first year we're
going to have a much larger admissions period
after that first year that's going to typically
most students will come in come on grounds
start to take some prerequisites and then apply
over the summer and then the transfer just like i
just like i talked about either internal or
external the important part of that is to
develop those relationships with the two-year
schools and then match the courses so they can
transfer over as many credits as possible and then
we will have plus one programs so eventually once
the master's program kind of changes a little
bit so we will allow students to go through the
undergraduate and then just get one year masters
all right so students can envision themselves
moving through even into graduate school is
an important precedent to student success okay
incentives okay so i have three three things
to talk about here incentives is broadly
defined but these are incentives really for us as
program managers to make sure that we're tracking
uh you know tracking certain elements of the
diversity of our student pool that we're hitting
certain targets so we have to build these things
in right from the beginning otherwise um kind of
trying to inject them into the culture later can
be can be quite difficult so incentives mean what
are the incentives for us to make sure that we're
doing this on a regular basis throughout the life
of this program and not just thinking about
it kind of ad hoc so one way that we can do
that and again jack is familiar with these
because he's been very involved in this but
is to build in requirements for diversity into
the actual evaluation of the program that we
will send to the state regulating body so we
just foreground it up front and say hey that
we're you know we want to match the diversity of
the populations here at uva we say that because
that is the population which we are restricted to
we hope to influence that to make it more diverse
as the stool starts to come up and becomes
more attractive but we are constrained to the
students that are here so we want to make sure to
match or exceed the kind of existing demographics
at uva and here we have hugs is defined
as historically underrepresented groups
we have a pretty broad definition of what that
means but we want that six year graduation rate
to be at 95 percent and then uh down here at
the bottom two is this last one all right that
i just highlighted a few of these there and
these are on all the metrics that we're using
these are kind of the ones that we're building
into the actual governing documents that we're
sending to the state but i think it's important
to put these in here just to make sure that uh
we get it right right from the beginning okay so
robust measures for student success this includes
not just uh how are they doing in terms of
just you know kind of wrote gpa but also
matching it to learning outcomes and engagement
so engagement can play a huge factor and we know
through through you know probably pushing
30 years of research now that engagement
is directly related to um you know self-efficacy
and student performance and even post-graduate
um you know student success in
the broadest sense so engagement
is really about how involved they are with the
university community which is again linked to
tinto's model associated with dropout rates that
the higher they are engaged with the university
the better they do across the board on all sorts
of different things so it's important for us
to think about when we're measuring student
success to not just think about it as how many
students are passing similar to what we just
showed on the previous slide but to be kind of
all-encompassing about that all right so there's
lots of research here that kind of supports that
to show that there's you know a strong correlation
between um you know thinking about student
engagement and success very broadly this one
measure here is kind of a holistic measurement
approach that includes not only gpa or credit
accumulation but also the level of engagement
right so the more you measure a thing especially
as they found in this particular article here
is that the students there was a pretty big
differential between students that showed high
levels of engagement in terms of self-efficacy
and self-esteem and that related directly
towards higher student performance so they're
measuring these two things continuously all right
and this is just a this is a meta study that
tried to look and um and just to quantify a
bit better based off all the years of
research we put into this you know is
this actually true that engagement can lead to
achievement they went across 70 studies here
you know 200 000 participants and they found
that there were pretty strong connections
between achievement and high levels of
engagement right across all of these studies
so we know this to be true and so it's important
when you think about designing the program is
that we think about student success as broadly as
possible all right so uh we also need systematic
processes for student feedback all
right so we need to engage students
in their own learning and provide avenues for them
to provide you know honest feedback especially as
we're just starting to build this we want to
understand what works and what does it you
know and it actually increases engagement right so
akin to what i just talked about in the previous
slide anything that we could do to further engage
students in their own learning increases their own
self-confidence right and it helps to retain
minority and first generation students right
all right the next point here is that
students really need to see themselves
in the degree all right so this what i mean by
that is that it's important for black students to
see black professors for hispanic students to see
hispanic professors for women to see themselves in
the professors that are looking back at them all
right and it's just not it's not just professors
it's teaching assistants or alumni speakers or
even certain case studies right that we use in
class right and another thing that this could
manifest in is upper level students participating
in the early career of the more junior students
right so get students involved with students and
thinking about how to match them up in terms
of race and ethnic and background matching
we know can make a significant difference in
student performance in particular retention
right i want to highlight this one because
i've got some additional points i'm going
to talk about you know later in the presentation
about how this one in particular works all right
uh so here all right this is just some
research that shows this all right
in terms of just seeing themselves in the degree
all right the study here was a greater faculty
diversity it led to significant increases in the
um outcomes of students especially as it related
to african american students in terms of them
just matching and seeing themselves in the degree
all right so this was one that was done at
a higher at higher education institutions it
seemed like it was a very good predictor of gpa
and overall graduation if students were matched
up with uh race-matched teachers and mentors
all right similar study uh it just focused on
this is through k-12 right focused on the impacts
of particular um race-based matching in the k-12
system and it found that overall that there were
some maybe not as strong correlations as we saw in
the previous study but that scores on standardized
tests for those students that were race and ethnic
matched were significantly higher all right and
they had better behavioral outcomes associated
with um in classroom um performance so both at
higher education at the higher education level
we think about you know post post secondary and in
k through 12 it seems to be significant difference
here in uh in these two studies as it relates to
just the benefits of this race matching all right
so the next thing that we think about here is um
student support services so uh we've talked about
a number of points here that
are important again to kind of
increase diversity and retain diversity students
inside your program and having once they're here
on campus providing support services is going
to be a critical one now this this particular
point there's a lot there's a lot to cover here
but i'm going to try and isolate it down um
to specifically peer mentoring all right so
i've talked about this idea of building social
capital and we know that one of the best ways
to do that as we've already seen in some of the
research examples is to get students in front
of students that have the same lived experience
so this one here this example is is is really
pretty impressive you know so this first year
this is a chemistry laboratory that has problems
with retention year over year in terms of dropping
out but they went to kind of a model that included
peer mentors in a cohort program and they're able
to increase student retention by 20 year after
year just by implementing this kind of simple
peer mentoring program they even highlight here
the program is uncomplicated and requires just
modest resources right and significantly increased
stem retention in this particular program
all right here's another example for
peer mentoring and social capital gain
all right so this was a um a study that focused
on a hispanic serving institution all right where
they they looked at about uh 450 students and
they were matched with mentors over three years
and then they analyzed that data and they found
that the mentees reported increased university
integration and post-testing significantly greater
than the non-mentor students and so this is akin
to what we talked about earlier about engagement
and how they can make a huge difference and where
students are engaged and they're integrated into
community they're much less likely to drop out
and stay and complete their degree and
this type of peer mentoring can make a
huge significant difference in that um as this
study kind of articulates especially with this
minority population this is the last one here
and this is kind of a well-known well-known study
of the university of texas el paso i'm sorry
that this rendered kind of badly but i'll hit
you through the highlights here we can see at the
very bottom here that um what happened is that the
they were they went from kind of they had a very
significant problem with retention year after year
especially from first to second year which
is very common all right so they went to
a more community-based model right which
included peer mentors of older uh students
inside the program right coming and speaking with
new students and developing those relationships
uh over time all right so this is a population
university that had over 80 percent was hispanic
and if we just go all the way down to
the bottom they did some other things
too about applying kind of active learning
concepts and immersing them into research
but peer mentorship was one of the things
that they developed in the community
and let me just highlight this down here and again
i'm sorry it's a little hard to read but they saw
that their retention rates by implementing these
series of programs nearly doubled from 43 to 80
um and then the average time for graduation
decreased by almost two years that that is
a that is an amazing uh improvement um and
it this is a holistic change they did a lot
of things here so it wasn't just peer mentoring
but a big key of it was getting those students
in front of other students and trying to help them
develop those relationships and find be integrated
and supported into the campus and then uh it it
really had just a dramatic impact as we can see
in terms of retaining those students all right
uh students life support okay so we actually
flip that around but anyway these are the final
things here we need we do need to think about
not just kind of this peer mentor i just want
to hit some more of these highlights you know
that there are real financial concerns and so
we're thinking about private partnerships in the
firms of um scholarships and then also kind of
reduce tuition rates inside the school and then
you know academic we really do need to get them
tutoring and i had some success in the past
in terms of developing interest networks
around specific topics and that might be
you know neuroscience or biomedical medicine
whatever that might be to get those students
together and then start just talking about those
concepts through shared through shared interests
one that has a tendency to work really well as
social good and and sports actually when you think
about the specific instances that might occur in
data science programs okay the last one here is uh
is is about pedagogy all right so we've kind of
gone through um you know the opportunities that we
have in data science where we're at for that right
we've gone through how to develop these two-year
relationships and some techniques associated
with how we can support these students
but it's also important that we think
about just not you know the environment
to get them here and then all the support services
but also what happens inside the classroom so
there's a lot of research that associates
active based learning to improve retention
and minority especially in minority and
first generation students right this is
an example here right that talked about a program
associated with underrepresented minority students
that uh proved to show significant
increases in terms of their um
ability to uh just retain the course and then also
to um perform as compared to when they did not
implement this active base program there's
about 250 students in this particular one
and it supports as it says on the bottom there a
significant amount of research that uh inclusive
um that active activity-based um pedagogy really
does help with inclusive teaching and pathways
for a diverse standard workforce all right
this one should be behind the one before it but
i can just tell you that it's the same as this
particular one here i just wanted to highlight
this again because one of the things that they did
and again in this well-known study
at the university of texas el paso
is that they in they immersed
students into research projects
right from the beginning so they
were problem-based problem-based uh
labs and they were supported with faculty and
they actually uh worked them through a research
process as one of the first things they did when
they got on campus so as compared to maybe just
kind of these are the electives you have to
take your first year that every student takes
they immerse these students into a community-based
learning environment and then had them in there
doing training uh very hands-on applied active
learning based methods doing problem-based
problem-based learning and research experiences
right in their first year and that again
contributed to this significant difference in
um in retention year after year almost doubling
okay so uh active learning does well there it
is so i put it up kind of without it all right
this is duplication and just to emphasize this so
we're trying to do some things here at the school
we've submitted a lab to the president's and
provost fund for data science active learning lab
as one of the project goals here we wanted
to kind of encourage the creation of cultural
norms as it relates to how data science is
taught especially in the undergraduate space
right the proven benefit um to improve
outcomes for underrepresented groups
and first generation students and the idea is that
we're we want to take this content you know about
how we can create these kind of activity-based
labs and learning structure and just make it free
and open right to encourage other data science
undergraduate programs to take these things and
implement them all right so if we know that they
work not only they work for minority and first
generation and underrepresented groups they work
for everybody right so student performances in
terms of learning outcomes uh appear to be
clearly linked to this type of pedagogical
approach but especially as it relates to these
groups of students that we're thinking about
so this is one of the ways that we're trying
to develop this kind of as a cultural norm
in the school and then hope it occur encourage
this type of activity outside the walls of uva
we also have a collaboratory for the advancement
of education and data science it's called kids
all right and so the goal here is to really you
know facilitate an opportunity for uva faculty and
students to work together right engage not only
in data but also partner with the schools as well
and so this is related to all the things that
we talked about you know trying to get students
involved in research partnerships as much as we
can and we're also focusing on projects that kind
of directly related to some of these goals and
then uh over the summer as an instance i have i
have three undergraduate students that are going
to help me on these projects that we're doing
as part of the collaboratory and we're really
just getting started so we're hoping to have
you know kind of a robust portfolio of
projects that are in the education space
that we can engage students in that will not only
increase you know their engagement just on campus
but also that the outcomes of these particular
research projects could benefit the field at large
given the time constraints i won't get into the
details of the two of those but uh also this
is our view of data science uh i'm happy to ask
questions about this um but we see we see it as
very balanced across these four pieces um and this
is the way that we're designing the undergraduate
programs analytics is is typically what people
think of when you think of data science machine
learning statistics designs associated with
communication of data science tools and actually
the designing of kind of human centered design
products systems is everything we need to be able
to do the to do the data sciences everything
from coding to high performance computing to
cloud-based systems and then value is kind of what
we think about is the ethical and policy elements
associated with data science and how we use these
algorithms ethically and think about the human
impact and practice as you might suspect is how we
put it all together so this is how we're designing
the programs as a whole and then this is kind
of what the actual program in the undergraduate
looks like i'm happy to ask more questions about
that but i'm trying to leave it at a high level
the concentrations will be in each one of those
domain areas which is another i think unique
feature so students can see themselves if they
have a tendency to be less computational or less
computer science oriented that we have design
and ethical elements associated with this field
so we're trying to creep it as broad as
possible which is another tenement we think
that would lead to increased diversity of the
students coming into the undergraduate program
so with that that's it thanks ryan
thank you so much um obviously we're
you're leading the the the uh effort here at uva
to build these curriculums and frankly i this is
just the first i'm sure we're going to see these
popping up all across the country and recruiting
diversity into them is vitally important and you
touched on a number of different areas i'm curious
about the possible recruitment opportunities
that may also exist maybe you didn't touch on
for example reaching out to um historically
black colleges and universities to see if
there's interested in kind of cross-pollinating
students or any activities like that i'm curious
if you could comment on that also about um are
there any organizations such as the women in
data science organization that possibly might be
a a a way for greater um i don't know just for for
women to see data science as a possible career
path for them not maybe they're not quite used to
it but maybe there's a way through organizations
such as that to kind of get the word out um
and also at the level of high school um
you know if you can catch people before
they decide on where their college trajectory
is maybe there's a way to get more people there
these are just a couple different things that
i wanted to see if you had some comments on
yeah yeah absolutely so start at the top that
hbcus is a great you know we've done that we
did that at gw a good bit actually we partnered
with them we had research symposiums and we made
sure to have you know kind of representation from
these you know historic um you know black minority
institutions and that that helped out a lot
right and i think we all learned from each other
and i think there's opportunities to continue
to do that through kind of dedicated programming
whether that comes in the form of summer
research programs or whether we even think about
creating pathways for those types of students
if they wanted to transfer into our program
i think that's an important thing to consider um
and so yeah so at the k through 12 well let
me start with the um kind of women's and data
science they're actually fairly lucky here at uva
so they're pretty active kind of women in stem and
latino and stem club groups but there's also these
national groups as well and we have a conference
here as you know to support women in data science
every year and i you know in thinking about these
things that you know it's i think we're actually
got a pretty good head start on kind of creating
these cultural norms because of all this activity
in the field related to getting more diverse
voices in it you know it's a nice time to be
starting a program like this because so you
get so much support for this type of ideal and a
lot of that's already taking place so some of this
you know outside of the actual creation of this
undergraduate degree i think when you think about
you know where it sits in the larger landscape
it's just a matter of making sure to engage in
those and do it purposely i think we're doing
a pretty good job here hosting a conference
every year relative to women in data science but
there's always certainly things you can do more
in the k-12 area we've actually started in adam
donaldson um adam yeah it's been working with
um working with the state of virginia
to develop kind of programming in the k
through 12 space i think that's like the i
mean if not the current you know co-frontier
with undergraduate we certainly been getting a lot
of requests about how we can inject data science
into that and that would help us out tremendously
because i mean that what we're the reason we have
a three-year degree and not a four-year degree
is we're worried that students are going to come
to campus not really know what data science is
um and so we're trying to give them a year to
understand that and that's why they have to take
a couple of data science courses their first year
but over time you know if we can evolve the
landscape of data science education or computer
science and you know computational computational
methods in the k-12 system that would actually
allow us to have a much you know maybe even get a
year back right we'd have a larger amount of space
bring in students earlier and then push the
curriculum even further and so i know that
initiatives are active in several states about
that and i think they're piloting a program
uh next year that will focus on just kind of data
science applied to to finance very very high at a
high level to give students in the k-12 experience
not just in the you know not just in not just in
data science broadly but apply it to an area with
which they might be interested and there's a lot
of nonprofit organizations there's one in new york
that's pretty well known that's doing that same
thing and offering kind of uh going around and
offering in high schools and community colleges
right where high school students can go and
take classes applied data analytics uh data
sports analytics courses where they can get kind
of minority students or underrepresented students
kind of excited about these applications through
the domain of sports which seems to be working
pretty well yeah that's great it's uh yeah
um which kind of brings me to in measuring
postgraduate job success so we've provided this
education and we have women and minority data
scientists are charging out into the workforce
do are we prepared to measure their job success
and uh one of our participants asked what is
the optimal or equitable representation in your
opinion of the minority groups in the data science
workforce that we should try strive to achieve
well we wanted to mirror the general population
of them in the u.s right so from an economic
standpoint we can think about students think about
a population of those that are actively seeking
work we know what the demographics of that are
and there's no reason that stem careers shouldn't
mirror that i mean i many of the opportunities
especially as it relates to generational wealth
and success come through stem education we
know there's research that supports that idea
and so for us to have disproportionate um you know
minority groups that are working in that is is
is a concern across the board right even for
the future what we think about kind of economic
you know benefits of those groups so i think
that's that should be the minimum goal um and
then you know i think we should think about you
know what our real aspirations are to try and to
try and excel that i mean part part of the problem
is that we we're doing fairly well when you think
about just um you know diversity overall in terms
of in terms of people going into either two or
four year degrees but retention is still such a
huge problem we still lose like on average 30 of
all college students drop out every year right
and it's higher for minority students and first
generation students you know it's like closer
to of that population you know they make up an
unbalanced percentage of it a higher percentage
you know in a 10 million students a year
you know that's that's that's 300 000 students
that are either withdrawing or going to part-time
or removing out of uh out of the education system
so you know i think that that's a big problem so
we need to fix that so why a lot of this talk was
focused on not just identifying and getting in the
pipeline but how do we support them appropriately
to increase and make sure that they persist um
so i think that that's the first step in trying to
try and balance that out and i you know we think
about post graduation success there are some there
are some some programs that do very well with this
um and they keep track of their graduates over
over more than like a 10-year period you know
the data science field i think is is fairly
i mean even though it's well it's it's just
young right so it's only been around for really
you know in a very robust way you know probably
less than like six or seven years but i think we
need to start thinking about it's a good point
about what it means to be successful after
graduation and then what does it mean to be
you know generationally successful especially
for first generation students you know or their
or their children then moving on and having
college success you know there's an important
economic indicator of upward mobility this kind of
generational social capital that gets passed down
from graduates to graduates so hopefully we can
kind of think about that but there's a good point
brian are there any other kind of lessons learned
about what does not work in promoting diversity
yeah i i so that's a it's a good point this is
all about what does work i i think you know i
i think being passive doesn't work i'll just say
that i think that you really have to be aggressive
and go out and and try and recruit these students
i think a lot of ways we've set up scholarships
uh when i was at gw we had some scholarships
that were available but the bad part about it
is they actually ended up using all the money and
that's because students weren't even aware that
it was there right so you really you really gotta
get you know you gotta get out your shoes and hit
the street i mean develop these relationships
with the two-year schools like go into high
schools and let people know the availability you
have to rely on your institutions for some of this
but i think you know the other thing that is
important is to experiment right i mean a lot of
the studies that we showed here they made kind of
dramatic changes and then tracked and solid work
there's a lot more studies that that probably
don't get published where they try things and
and didn't work either but i think it's important
to have kind of an experimental you know approach
to this to see what works but i think the most
important thing is to just not not be passive
you know we we had a really nice program at gw
when i was there that was funded through the nsf
one of the examples of maybe something that did
work as compared to the billions that didn't
where we would any student that went
through um community college there
northern virginia community college and got
an it degree got admitted um automatically
uh and their tuition was paid for to come into the
gw um information technology bachelors and if they
got through that program then i we would pay for
their masters in data science so that we could go
to the northern virginia community college and
say if you make it through this use your gpa is
3.0 make it through this program you get into the
bachelor's run we'll pay for that and if you make
it through that then we'll pay for your master's
program um and that was great we had a ton of
success recruiting students to go through that
pipeline and that was all supported through uh
through nsf but we couldn't just put it up on
a website we had to go out there and actively
recruit and it's hard i mean that students are
afraid to go through these things they're very
they're afraid of afraid of failure you know it's
high risk and they have they have to be honest i
think that that a lot of people uh come from
environments where you know it might actually
not even be encouraged right to pursue this type
of thing and so there's there's a lot of hurdles
there to get over but i do think that getting out
there and making meaningful relationships a lot of
what we talked about in terms of developing kind
of that social capital is critical it just doesn't
work unless you're out there and kind of build
those pathways and with purpose are there any
in kind of i guess it's almost like an intangible
but maybe it's measurable are there any examples
of where increased diversity of the technical
workforce on any particular problem in data
science ai machine learning where increased
diversity has reduced biases that are present
in ai and data set algorithm development or a
data collection or the presentation of results
from ai you know machine learning uh algorithms i
i know that seems a little nebulous but i'm just
kind of curious if there's a if there's an actual
payoff in terms of the robustness the reliability
and the suitability of kind of the answers
that we're getting from ai technologies based
on diversity i don't have any studies that i can
point to that quantifiably say yes but um i have
had you know a lot of conversations and and people
may be familiar with this name with kathy o'neill
and and she talks about kind of implementing
these you know kind of ethical frameworks and um
she wrote a really well a well-known book called
um weapons of mass destruction but you know that
that kind of idea like to inject that actually
comes typically from kind of a social science
background the idea is up front is to think about
the human element associated with how the model
will be implemented or how can it go wrong or what
are the things we can control and not control and
that type of like quasi-experimental design
like on the front end has a tendency to come
from social science backgrounds and those as we
saw in some of these slides ahead especially as
it relates to women habits have a tendency to be
much more diverse so i mean it might be a leap
of faith right to suggest that that is true but i
mean if you kind of walk that line of logic back
we know that you know having a having a
thoughtful you know putting the science back
in data science if you will you know kind of this
you know approach to foregrounding the problems
and then using some of these ethical frameworks
that are already there is something that is
probably much more um i would say normative
right in some of the less harder sciences and so
kind of the more human-centered um social
sciences which have a tendency to be more diverse
so the answer to the question could be yes yeah
nicole um suggests that scott page has written
a bunch about the quote unquote diversity
bonus and how one might quantify it so for
anybody who's interested that might be a place to
place to look um any parting comments for us brian
uh thanks for your time you know if you want to
follow up or have questions about any of these
things i you know i i love talking about it so
i'd be happy to dig in deeper and um you know just
just reach out but that's it he will be um he is
one of our mentors um for those of you who are
taking part in our innovation lab next month uh
brian is one of our mentors so you'll get a lot
of chance to interact with him and ask him a lot
of questions and uh have some hopefully really
deep conversations about how to boost diversity
and equity um in data science and how we can
kind of think about ways to make that payoff
uh brian thank you so much for a really great
discussion about how we can infuse diversity
into undergraduate data science education
such an important topic again i hope everybody
will reach out to him so thank you so very much
everyone this concludes our series of the data
science uh biomedical data science seminar
series and i want to thank all of you who have
joined us each week i want to thank all of our
speakers who have done such a fantastic job
everybody can find their talks on youtube
and hopefully you will watch them again you'll
share them you'll use them as foundational content
for our innovation lab next uh next month for
those of you who are watching on youtube i hope
this is an important resource for you it's always
a joy when people approach me kind of randomly and
say how much they've enjoyed watching the seminar
series and how much they get out of these videos
so thank you so very much um and i certainly
would be remiss if i did not say thank you to
gina kamdar and to hannah reichel who have
made a just they just make this run like
like a swiss watch it's really fantastic to have
them um helping me every day uh and so for those
of you um who are taking part in our innovation
lab next month we really look forward to seeing
you uh we are so excited to do this in person
i cannot tell you um in the meantime everyone
have a great weekend have a great summer we'll be
starting our innovation lab or sorry a biomedical
data science seminar series once again in
the fall term the topic of which will be
to be determined but uh watch this space and
uh we hope to be able to come up with a number
of other fantastic speakers uh to
present to you so thank you everyone